this is my son Charlie and his
girlfriend hi so Jerry is our new
neighbor hey hey
Fright Night Stars Anton Yelchin Colin
Farrell David Tennant Toni Collette emo
ghen Poots and McLovin cuz I ain't
saying his full name it's a remake of a
1980s horror film and a lot of people
were like you know doesn't really have
to be remade you know it's not that kind
of eerie make and you know let's face it
they're remaking just about everything
it's directed by Craig Gillespie who
directed mr. Woodcock and Lars and the
real girl which was really good and I
don't know what there were mr. Woodcock
is doing in there it's about a kid and
his mom or trying to sell their house
yes they're not moving into a house in a
neighborhood they're trying to get out
of the neighborhood it's not like oh we
moved into a new house and there's a
crazy weirdo next door it's not like
that you know it's not cliched and Colin
Farrell's living next door and they
start to notice some interesting things
about him some weird things they can't
really explain Colin Farrell is not
normal
Adam Johnson Adam you know Adams missing
right kids aren't coming to school it
happens all the time that guy your
neighbor since he moved in people are
disappearing Gerry Colin Farrow is so
good in this movie I've always really
liked him I really liked him in Minority
Report and I never really thought that
he got the attention that he deserved he
owns this movie chews up like every
scene he's in he just owns every scene
very physical and you know just in the
sieve very present in this movie and I
know I know you know what I mean by
present cuz every single actor who's in
a movie either their president but Khan
Ferrell was he was in this movie I mean
he was just aa pentagon Yeltsin is also
really good actually the whole cast is
good I really liked everyone David
Tennant was really funny
3d movies when they were in the 80s and
kind of popular most of time it was it
was the horror films like jaws 3d and
some of the Friday the 13th movies that
was when 3d was really popular and then
it kind of died down for a while and now
it's coming back again and now that's
coming back again I really like that
some scary horror films are using it I
really think that 3d is just exactly
perfect for this type of film because
this movie is so self-aware of what it
is it knows that it's kind of cheesy and
corny however it embraces that and
that's kind of exactly what 3d is 3d is
kind of corny I mean who goes to a movie
where it's a serious film that to be
like something's coming out of me oh boy
it like 3d at its core is kind of cheesy
and corny so it fits perfectly with this
movie and with horror films hey guy
you've been watching me I've been
watching you your mom gives off a scent
and your girl she's ripe it's on you to
look out for them you up hood I really
like the look of this movie the dark
look of the suburban town kind of like
Disturbia or Shia LaBeouf I really dug
the atmosphere in this movie really
seriously helped this movie Colin
Farrell does not sparkle in this movie
he is just he's evil you know he's he's
loving and he's fun he's just a force of
nature in this film his characters I
can't say it enough he's the heart of
this movie the heart the score of the
film is really well done the direction
is very tense lots of suspense is just
like strain from the scenes kind of what
I want to don't be afraid of the dark to
be like just really suspenseful I
enjoyed don't be afraid of dark but this
film is much more scary
but stay
the characters in this film are
believable I mean I know some of them
are really over-the-top but the main
lead Anton Yelchin and his girlfriend
and the mother those three characters
you there's there's a real relationship
there that that adds a lot of weight to
the film that's necessary for you to
feel invested in the characters when all
the crazy stuff starts happening there's
also an excellent scene in this film
made to look all one shot all one take
and it's just I've had see my favorite
scene in the whole movie my problems
with the film are very few actually
really the only thing I didn't like
where there were some scenes where Anton
Yelchin kinda went out of the town into
the big city and he met David Tennant
there who I liked in the film think that
took away a bit of the field because I'm
not sure the filmmakers were aware how
well the film was working being closed
in that little city in that little town
this very claustrophobic cuz when he
left a town it sort of made the film
feel a little more open like okay we
have room to breathe now and it took
away from the tension of the movie a
little bit that was really my only
problem with the film so I had a lot of
fun with Fright Night the acting was
great the the direction was really good
that it was very tense it was just a lot
of fun I loved the 3d horror stuff it
was just it all worked really well for
the movie I really enjoyed it
I'm gonna give it an a- did i kill him
Fright Night tomorrow I will see Conan
and guess what else I'm seeing my kids
for I can't wait to review that movie so
like my review subscribe to my channel
and gets stuck my eyes